tropical storm nage made landfall in the
Philippines late Friday evening but 24
hours later it wasn't quite done yet by
Sunday morning nearly the entire
archipelago was submerged in flood water
Eduardo Ballesteros says he wasn't able
to get any sleep
it's the first time this has happened to
us we've been wet since last night we
can change because all our clothes are
wet and some were even Swept Away we've
lost so much even our chickens died
Lisa Flores one of Eduardo's neighbors
says she feared for her life and her
children
my two little daughters were home what
if they drowned and our house collapsed
we would have been buried alive
fortunately while flood waters continued
to rise in other areas they were slowly
receding in their neighborhood I want to
give you a sense of How High flood
waters Rose here right now it's ankle
deep but look at this dark pink streak
over the light pink paint of the gate
this was how high the flood waters were
thousands of Filipinos are still in
temporary shelters social workers here
say it may take a few days before
evacuees can return to their homes
social welfare secretary Irwin tulfo
assures victims that the government is
ready to provide the necessary Aid going
Depot today health is on its way if it
doesn't arrive today it will arrive
tomorrow morning that's the latest you
can expect it no matter where you are
thank you for now some Filipinos are
going around and donating Food Packs an
act of kindness victims say is
unexpected but the welcome gesture their
faith in humanity restored during one of
the most trying times Barney below Al
Jazeera emu City the Philippines